[Music]
now the oscar-nominated actress stars as
former cia agent
robin mccall in a tv reboot of cbs's
show the equalizer
robin mccall is a vigilante who fights
for truth and justice for those in need
in this preview she's talking to her
former cia handler you know him too
that's chris knoth about what keeps her
up at night
you could come work for me babysitting
billionaires
an oil company private security is just
like working for the cia except the pace
a lot better
oh hell it's all the same chessboard you
know that
i see that's the problem right there
everybody's playing chess nobody's
thinking about the living breathing
pieces that we sacrifice along the way
you know it's funny
queen latifah hi he's also an executive
producer
good morning to you dana oh it's good to
see you
may i just say this about the show
already i'm gonna go on a limb and say
i've seen it you got a hit on your hands
but i remember when you were a little
girl and you were saying you chose the
name queen latifah because it meant
delicate kind sensitive one all of the
things you are but this
this character robin mccall is a badass
she kicks butt he takes numbers
so i'm i'm also told that they wrote
this with you and mine
so when they approached you you thought
yeah i want this job
yeah um preliminary bookway actually
brought this project to me
um at universal television and she said
uh
so we're thinking about you for the
equalizer and i was like
yes have you watched it were you
familiar with it did you watch it
had you seen the denzel movie and seen
the old cbs show
um yes i did i used to watch the old cbs
show
and i loved that show and i just
i thought to myself like the opportunity
to be able to get to play action again
and to to do those fun things the
the sort of uh it's it came full circle
all the things that i've done in my
career and in my life
um and being a raised by attack
officers you know tactical officers kid
and
you know a vietnam vet and a school
teacher
and so all these like the emotion of of
saving lives and
getting justice um has always been
something big in my household
yeah and um to be able to bring that to
the screen and to
especially at this time when we need it
so much i thought it was important
your dad as you mentioned your dad was a
police officer in newark for what about
18 years i think right
is is this in any way kind of an homage
to him um
always an homage to him always an homage
to him because
you know he put his life on the line he
did it every day and
he's he's been a long you know he's
helped me
uh through my whole career he's gone
with me everywhere i've gone
um all my movies all my movie sets and
just
been there to to support me and to help
me out and to make sure everything was
safe
and i was safe and so you know um
this is this is a big one queen uh this
is tony decouple here
the show is fiction and exciting fiction
at that but it's also dealing with real
world facts
of racial inequality how do you balance
uh that that jump from
from entertainment to taking on real
issues
i think we the goal was to take on real
issues to kind of take things that are
ripped from the headlines and to
um you know to
inject them into the show and we didn't
know
when we started this back in you know
late last year um that our world would
turn upside down
um that things that we needed to face
and confront would be um
brought to the forefront in such a
horrific and and
um acute way uh
but it's time you know it's it's time a
lot of people want justice they want to
see it
exactly they feel like meaningless they
feel like
everything they've done is like not
worth it um
and we want to give some hope and at the
same time we want to
we want to you know let the good guys
win for a change
you know let the little guy win for a
change or a little girl
in in our opening episodes case um
but but you know to see someone with uh
robin mccall's expertise
use that for the everyday person
not just for people with money in power
is really what we about
you know black women have been
equalizing for years
you know from you gail to stacey abrams
to your best friend oprah
you know uh we have been doing this for
for years and years and years
our mothers our grandmothers have been
fighting uphill battles and and even in
this uh
pandemic and um economic downturn
we've borne the brunt of of this
economic uh
and uh physical um disparity
and we're gonna have to pull it up again
you know what i mean
i'm so glad to see you though as a lead
you know a female lead black female lead
in the show so i'm very excited and very
proud about that
i'm curious when you talk about justice
there's a big story bubbling up today in
the country music world about morgan
wallin
who was caught on tape using the n-word
and now there's word that
his career may be over what does he need
to do how can he rehabilitate
you know there are mixed voices coming
in on this do you think his career
should be over
is there a chance for redemption and
second chances here what did you think
when you heard about this story
i just caught i barely caught a whiff of
this last night because as you can see
i got this big huge set behind me i was
on this thing
late into the early to late so i don't
have a lot of time to catch you
all right that's right you don't want to
comment if you're not familiar so i get
that
but let's talk about this redemption for
you know as a as a child of christ i
think it's redemption for everyone you
know but i think you got to seek it and
want it
and you know we've seen the best and
worst come out of people over the last
year
and it's time for people to seek the
best in themselves and find their
northern campus again
they've lost their moral compass and um
it's time for them to figure out
which way is north which way is south
east and west because the
everybody's doing this yeah people need
to figure it out
you know what i mean you're so right i
like to when you said you got to seek it
you got to want it you got to seek it
that's so well set and
a special plug for living single no you
remember that show living single
do i remember that show on that show
thank you for asking about living
singles
so shawna thomas is our big cheese boss
over here she said
she wouldn't mind if you brought it back
so i'm just passing that along
do without what you will i'll take that
we've tried we're working on it
and um i actually i don't even i don't
even think i would have got this job if
perlina wasn't such a big
living single fan so i'll take that all
right
you got a lot of support cheering you on
always queen latifah
the show is called the equalizer
premieres his sunday hey good
positioning right after the super bowl
right here on cbs